[Music]
your movie wanderlust which uh we're
going to talk a lot about there's a lot
of references in the movie and i realize
it's true just looking at you now
characters actually other characters
talk about how beautiful your skin is
and then i see you in person and your
skin is just kind of perfect
and i'm wondering how you do that how
you don't touch it nothing oh yeah oh
it'll fall off yeah shoot
now i do you sort of glow i don't know
what it is is it you're something you're
eating i said this in an interview i i
became obsessed with laser
porn
and basically you know you is your porn
well i called it laser porn because once
somebody said you know i was like yeah i
could get a couple of these sun spots
because i like the sun you know i'm a
california girl and it's a hard habit to
break feels so good yeah but you know
you get to the place where it's like oh
maybe not so much and so i went and
investigated having some of those little
things zapped and
and i did this thing called like a it's
like a peel which is
extremely intense you don't really
understand that you actually look like
like like a battered burn victim for a
week and then and then it just
falls off starts to fall off your face
fell off for like like eight days and
then it just kept yeah i was you were
it's going to be horrifying horrifying i
do have it documented but
it was horrifying i hope you saved the
face afterwards
the the actual thing fell off yeah you
could i couldn't keep it in one intact
piece oh man that is ebay gold
[Laughter]